so when you asked about our we won I
would say that as we head towards
self-actualization what gives us if you
will transcendence and this is a deep
sense of meaning and purpose is when we
look at another and see ourselves and
that's where ego merges with all tourism
and you see when you look at the world
that way when you see the other as you
it is impossible for you to hurts
another is impossible for you that you
do not care what happens to the other
yeah and so instead of looking at
another person as separate from yourself
you see them as yourself and that is
transcendence and that is when you
structure how you walk in the world with
that belief that is true meaning and
contentment and purpose when every
action you take is for the benefit of
the other
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don stock Ian we are on
site at the transformative technology
conference for our second partnership
with them we are now gonna be talking
about compassion science and so much
more we have dr. James Doty joining us
on the show thank you for having me I
appreciate it I'm so pumped for this
what an incredible record that you have
behind you of flowering the
consciousness of the civilization
universe I'm so pumped to dive in with
you we have to start with this question
we've been obsessed with this question
it's going to be so interesting to hear
your thoughts are we really all one yes
you want me to expound them please so if
you sort of go back a little bit and for
most of the world they're just trying to
survive and in fact most people don't
have time actually for deep reflection I
mean you know 50% of population lives on
$2 and 50 cents a day their life is a
struggle to survive if you were to look
at Maslow's hierarchy of needs beyond
that and frankly it's a blessing to be
there you have more time to have
self-reflection you have more time to
connect with people your life does not
only revolve around survival and within
that area there's a subset of people who
are trying to answer the question of why
am I here that's very natural question
our species is unique in that we are the
most evolved to have something called
theory of mind to have complex language
to have abstract thinking and a natural
sequence of that or following of that is
what is my purpose why am I here why do
I exist now you could be a nihilist and
say there is no purpose this was an
evolutionary accident
and you live you die that's it
and I not cannot necessarily argue
against that
but that being said what do we know is
true and you asked about compassion
science as a species unlike other
species our species require us the
parents if you will to care for our
offspring 15 years longer even and which
is a huge requirement and resources time
effort why do we do that the reason we
do that is because our offspring learn
from modeling through the mirror neuron
system and when we care when we connect
when we nurture our physiology has
evolved to work at its best and this is
true whether it's our offspring or
another's offspring although it is
limited by a defect in our evolution
which is the nature of tribalism and
when resources are readily available
people are much more open and accepting
when resources get scarce people have a
tendency to shut down and this is how
our autonomic nervous system works it
regulates our response to events and or
how we perceive events and when there's
scarcity we have a tendency to connect
with people who look like us act like us
what we define is our tribe we don't
share we're not as open that being said
the reality is that when there is
abundance and frankly I think scarcity
is an artificial construct when there's
abundance we're much more open and what
we know is that when you care for
another your physiology works its best
you feel good and in fact it stimulates
others to care to be compassionate and
to
try to if you will alleviate their
suffering which is what compassion is so
when you ask about are we one I would
say that as we head toward
self-actualization what gives us if you
will transcendence and this is a deep
sense of meaning and purpose is when we
look at another and see ourselves mmm
and that's where ego merges with
altruism and you see when you look at
the world that way when you see the
other as you it is impossible for you to
hurts another is impossible for you to
not care what happens to the other yeah
and so instead of looking at another
person as separate from yourself you see
them as yourself and that is
transcendence and that is when you
structure how you walk in the world with
that belief that is true meaning and
contentment and purpose when every
action you take is for the benefit of
the other yeah yeah spoken from a very
long amount of diverse stimuli that
you've taken in your life at the edge
and here you are synthesizing it all
into that eloquent story right there I'm
very curious is the root of all of our
issues the most upstream issue is that
we have these feelings of separation
separateness not the interconnectedness
I think that's exactly right I think
that the epidemic of loneliness stress
anxiety depression or manifestations of
disconnection from others and we know as
an example if you look at places in the
world
we're people routinely live to be over a
hundred you could argue that the reason
that is is because their physiology
works at its best their mental state is
at its best so what do we see in those
places we see environments where a
person's whole life is spent in
essentially the same place they have
grown up with the same neighbors they
live oftentimes with their parents their
grandparents their children all in
proximity or maybe even in the same
house and what does this person know
from the time their child to their death
they know that everyone accepts them
everyone loves them even for every part
of them that they think is not good
they're still loved and when you have a
sense that you are cared for and loved
and you're not afraid of judgments of
other people then your physiology works
very very well you know I have had the
pleasure and the joy of this pendant of
spending a fair amount of time with some
of the major spiritual and religious
leaders in the world including the Dalai
Lama Desmond Tutu tick not hon MA
Sri Sri Ravi Shankar Sadhguru Eckhart
Tolle and when you were in the presence
of an evolved individual what happens is
that those people have an extraordinary
capacity to give you unconditional love
and in the modern world what happens to
so many of us is we present a projection
of how we want to be perceived and not
how we truly are we will tell people you
know here is Who I am here is my title
here is what I've accomplished etc etc
etc and this is so we are can protect
ourselves against being judged when you
are in the presence of an individual
gives you absolutely unconditional love
a burden is lifted from you because the
weight of that psychological construct
you've created to protect yourself that
goes away you know people have said to
me you know Jim I saw you with the Dalai
Lama sitting next to him and talking
with him or with Amma and I could just
see that you had this smile and the
sense of joy and it's true because you
don't have to prove anything that person
just loves you unconditionally and if
someone can live that and feel that
about themselves
it's extraordinary but it's very hard
you know often times when I talk on
stage my voice will crack or I'll shed a
tear about a story I'm telling and I had
a woman come up to me and she said I'm a
psychiatrist and a hypnotist she said
you must have been embarrassed to buy
that you know if you spend three
sessions with me I can get rid of it
and I looked I started laughing I said
you know what happens though when I do
that I show my humanity and it allows
everyone to show theirs and invariably
in that situation almost everyone either
feels emotional or cries and I've never
seen a single instance where I've shown
my authenticity if you will or my
vulnerability that has not been rewarded
with people caring and hugging and
wanting to give and that is what all of
us want you know sometimes when I give
talks it's extraordinary because not
only is the audience crying but there's
a whole line of people who want to just
be hugged and that is how we should live
and connect with others you know people
talk about leadership all the time and
of course you know Google you know they
did the study to say what makes the best
teams what are the most successful teams
and after
this deep analysis it had nothing to do
with grade point average or what college
you went to domain experience it had to
do with showing your vulnerability being
authentic being non-judgmental and
creating an environment of psychological
safety and that says it all if you can
do that in the way you walked in the
world and not judge others it's profound
it's profound for you and it's profound
for them so that you know what what
before I came in here the individual
came up to me he said you probably don't
remember me he said we flight from here
to Chicago and what was that four or
five hours and he said our conversation
was so profound it changed my life
and you gave me these incredible
insights and I'll never forget it now I
hate to say this I actually don't
remember but my point is if we can spend
time with someone and in that
interaction with them you can be
completely with them where they feel
that that interaction with you has been
profound then that's a wonderful gift
and the reality is all of us can give
that gift to another because what it
takes is simply to be present yeah the
process of being present the process of
developing unconditional love the
process of developing the these feelings
of deep interconnectedness with all what
are some of the key strategies well I'm
not a Buddhist if I were to have a
philosophy to live by it would
incorporate some of the philosophies of
Buddhism and the reason I say that is I
think there are two particular aspects
that cause separation and cause
suffering one is ego two is craving and
three is attachment
and being attached to outcomes wanting
feeling you are important or above
another and realizing you're not and
striving to be in that position those
are the things that for most people
cause the most suffering and if you can
sit and be aware of the fact that it's
okay to have a goal or but if you don't
achieve your goal even though you've
tried it's okay you're not bad
if you can limit how you crave things
you know in Western society we have a
conspicuous consumption way of living
now if you look at the places where some
of the greatest wisdom traditions have
developed which is in the third world
people are satisfied because they're not
exposed to or at least they weren't
exposed to I need this I need that and
that'll make me happy whether it's a car
or a better car or a bigger car or
bowtie means washers whatever it is and
I'm not opposed in any way to having
things
it's the feeling that you have to have
them because by having them you feel
that that defines you in a certain way
you know from my perspective I would
like to believe that whether I had X
house or Y house or this watch or that
watch or this car or that if I don't
have them I'm exactly the same and as
you may know I went through an
experience where because of my own
background of scarcity if you will I
came from a challenging background of
poverty a father was an alcoholic a
mother who had had a stroke and was
paralyzed chronically depressed
attempted suicide
you know neither had gone to college we
were in public assistance and I thought
by having things and doing things and
achieving things that that meant success
and having had all of those things I was
never more unhappy in my entire life
because I would do something and say
well I didn't really get a whole lot out
of that I need to do the next thing and
the next thing and I wanted people to
look at me and say well he's successful
he's done it I had all my friends
telling me that yet none of it made me
feel good and what made me finally
understand and if you will get the
monkey off of my back that was driving
me was losing close to 80 million
dollars in six weeks and being bankrupt
and when I tell people is that
experience changed everything because it
was a period of reflection and I was
bankrupt but I had made some commitments
to charity and the only asset I had left
was stock in a company that had yet to
go public of which I had been the CEO
and when I was going through all the
legal stuff of you know basically
bankruptcy my lawyers told me that in
fact what I had thought I had given away
they had not processed the paperwork and
actually I could keep all the stock and
it would be worth tens and tens of
millions of dollars if the company would
public and I canvassed my friends and
100 percent of them said well I want to
give anything away but what I did was I
went ahead and lived up to those
commitments and gave everything away
which ended up being tens of millions of
dollars and I ended up funding
health clinics blood banks wing of a
hospital research endowed chairs and all
sorts of stuff around the world and
that's when actually I understood and
this relates back to our the other
earlier question on the one hand I had
everything and realized I had nothing
when I gave everything away when I had
nothing I got everything and that was
the transition from self interest to a
world view of service and connection to
the other and here's a question that so
many of us are aiming to figure out we
have identified what we are uniquely
blueprinted to do in this world we are
striving to achieve this beautiful gift
that we want to bring to ourselves our
families our communities and
civilization and the whole biosphere to
all that is to creation we want to bring
this unique gift forward and there does
there not need to be a process of
discernment of some sort of judgment of
me figuring out who the right people are
that I should spend these limited 2.5
billion seconds or heartbeats that I get
in my 82 year life that I should at
least be discerning with trying to
identify these other people that are
somewhat more blueprinted towards these
similar goals that I'm striving to
achieve well the reality is that for
most people a significant part of our
lives passed before we have any
discernment because what does
discernment come from
discernment comes from wisdom wisdom can
either be through reading watching for
most people it comes from experience by
not listening by not reading and
experience what others have gone through
but discernment frequently is a
manifestation of suffering and what I
mean by that is we have a tendency to
want to grasp and hold on to those
events that made us feel good I
accomplished this I graduate at the top
of my class I just bought this big house
etc etc and those of course result in
transitory
feeling of happiness and they're always
transitory and if you grasp for that all
the time that's where your attention
lies and a lot of people do that
and it's often times out of insecurity
or wanting others to look at them and be
jealous or to look at them and want to
be like them and that's ego the reality
though is that when you have experienced
the down parts of life's existence when
you have had downturns which have
resulted in pain and suffering when you
were distanced from them a bit you
realize how important they were for you
to learn and that's where discernment
occurs you start seeing the world in a
different way you start saying I don't
want to experience that again you start
saying this isn't helpful to me and I
think that's critically important at the
end of my pool at my house there's a
wall and on that wall water runs down
but in the center of it is a modern art
sculpture
of a Buddha and it's a modern art
sculpture because of two things one is
it doesn't have a head and the second
thing it sits with its hands between its
lacrosse legs and it's sitting with a
persimmon and so there are two aspects
of that and I consciously purchase this
sculpture for this reason one is the
Buddha without its head reminds me not
to get lost in my head but to focus on
my heart the persimmon is analogous to
what we just talked about
if you've ever eaten a persimmon it
starts out as hard and bitter but if
you're patient yeah it becomes soft and
sweet and that's the nature often of
experiences in our lives that are
painful when we reflect back on them
they've had incredible lessons and we
can look at them and say you know I see
why that happened or I'm so glad that
happened because it gave me this
incredible insight or this ability to
discern things more clearly treasures on
the other side of the traumas yes
exactly and so I with great intention
created that sort of place in my house
that I look at every day Jim we have to
ask you this as well what is the purpose
of creation well I could say I don't
[ __ ] know but perhaps a better
question is what do you think that
purpose is and then that of course shows
my own biases but it's not presented as
a fact
it is simply my belief in my opinion and
I would like to believe that whether
when we talk about the term oneness well
on the one level we look at each other
and as I said see the other issue but I
would suggest it even goes far far
beyond that you know some people have
used the term we're all Stardust and we
are we're all particles and whether we
are in this physical body or in a
different form of matter all matter is
connected and I think cosmology is
demonstrating that factually and so I
would suggest that there's no beginning
there's no end there's no separation and
when you see yourself in that way you're
part of everything and it's an
extraordinary way to think of yourself
that every bit of you touches every bit
of everything yes and it brings great
awe and joy and a sense of gratitude no
beginning no end no separation
I think you've summarized the world
summarize the world's philosophies and
those three words yeah which of you are
said you did it I led you down that and
it was very difficult we stand on the
shoulders of giants that we've learned
from these well you know it's
interesting because I think that what
we're talking about and remember our DNA
has not changed for the last 200,000
years
and this is why people from millennia
ago and when we had the first ability to
communicate with another to look at the
Stars
the to think deeply and share that deep
thinking a lot of this has been known
and frankly as much I was as I would
like to believe I have incredible
insight and self-awareness the fact of
the matter is almost everything if not
everything we've already talked about
has been thought of deeply by many many
other PPS and it would be great in terms
of ego to say it was my original thought
but I'm sorry it's not but I'm thankful
I've had the ability to learn from a
variety of people and you know the
interesting thing is oftentimes we'll
quote famous philosophers but some of
the greatest wisdom that has been
imparted to me are from some of the most
humble by appearance average people in
the world and even children and so you
know there's sometimes an arrogance that
people have about how they get
information or who useful information
can come from but frankly
anyone we can learn something from and
if you again walk in the world and
understand that everyone is a teacher
you just have to be a student and this
is the idea of the beginner's mind yes I
really want to ask you also about c-care
the Center for compassion and altruism
research and education neuro economic
models for altruism compassion
cultivation training potentially even
optogenetic techniques to influence
these incredible states this is so
important if we can catalyze this this
could lead to that next world that we
all want to be a part of well I think
the key is giving people tools that
allow them to live in this world and
thrive and I believe that by giving
people tools that allow them to be more
present and connected by giving them
tools that result in them diminishing
their stress and anxiety by giving them
tools that make them realize that with
every criticism they have for themselves
they're worthy of love that's what a lot
of people have challenges with of
accepting love because they feel they're
not worthy and they have a negative
dialogue that goes on in their head that
tells them that mm-hmm and when you give
them an understanding that that
negativity that voice is an artificial
construct and that they have immense
power within themselves which oftentimes
they give away to another by accepting
criticism about themselves by listening
to negative self-talk when they can
understand that reality then it allows
them to gain immense power and control
of their own reality you know events
have no power in themselves there's no
positive there's no negative yet what
happens to so many people is a memory
that they carry they attach an emotional
content to and when they relive it it
causes them suffering when you're able
to understand that these events only
have meaning if you give them meaning if
you understand that if you use the word
can't it's not possible than it is not
you know you simply need to look out at
others around the world who've
accomplished tasks that people have said
are not possible happen over and over
again yeah we have extraordinary
capacity within each of us to change our
reality it's whether you believe it
because once you believe it then you can
manifest it and one of the things is to
give people the ability to manifest
their own reality which then allows them
to be their best selves and to thrive is
what they're uniquely blueprinted for
and gifted to do in this world and build
a social fabric that enables that
flourishing and you gave these again
these three catalyzing presents
catalyzing unconditional love and these
feelings of interconnectedness that's so
beautiful
two quick questions on the way out this
one I feel may be a slight shocker maybe
to you do you feel as though humanity is
a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means you explain all of the
artificial general intelligence super
intelligence that we are building our we
is our role to build that well
apparently it is since we're doing that
I mean by definition if we're doing it
that is our role now the question is for
what purpose yeah
is the purpose to upload ourselves into
a machine and then no longer be
constrained by a body that dies and
that's an interesting proposition but
let me follow it with this observation
as you get more and more quote-unquote
intelligent why does that would that
intelligence have any interest in us
since it would so quickly bypass our
limited abilities it doesn't need us at
all you know there's a subset of the
billionaire class whose egos drive them
to think that somehow they should be
uploaded I mean it's ridiculous for a
couple reasons one is obviously it is
narcissistic and egotistical
exponentially who gives a [ __ ] about
that one billionaire often times that
billionaire is there by accident his
existence as presence as an accident of
fate you know I mean and I'm not saying
every billionaires a bad person I don't
want to imply that at all but there's
some subset of people who feel that
there are such high value to the world
that it is them that should be uploaded
and oftentimes they'll spend significant
resources to
promote this belief but oftentimes these
are some of the people who cause the
greatest problems you know why not
upload a person like Desmond Tutu why
not upload somebody like the Dalai Lama
why would you want to upload a
billionaire who oftentimes the very
nature of what they do is destructive to
so many people the most spiritually
enlightened rather than the most rich
yes because the very definition of
having that conversation is a separation
from the other as an example who gets to
be the first one who do you think it's
going to be is it a person in
sub-saharan Africa no are they going to
be the first ones on the next celestial
bodies oh yeah it's going to be the
0.001% and I don't necessarily think
they represent the best in humanity boom
there it is right there yeah you know
and the best that how do you measure
that by enlightenment or self
actualization or you know I mean as an
example why does an individual one
individual need 110 or 120 billion
dollars what is one individual need a
200 or 400 million dollar yacht why does
one individual need ten multi-million
dollar homes of which they're never at
what is that I mean why would you pick
those people who every action they take
demonstrates a sense of arrogance ego
versus someone who is in their world
having a profound profound impact by
fundamentally acting as if they have no
ego and their purpose is to connect with
the other and help them and that can be
it the most humble humble level I would
much rather have that person uploaded
than the other
Wow cool back and forth on that one okay
and then the very last question is what
is most beaut
in creation well I would suggest that
obviously that's very individual what I
would say is and actually this relates
to two experiences have you ever heard
of the toad the Sonoran desert toad who
for various 5mu DMT exactly so I you
know how to read stop said have you ever
heard of Huntress - yeah I heard you
know you know he was for the gonzo
journalist right he you know because of
the timing for yes he made a statement
you know I don't advocate the use of
drugs and alcohol but they worked for me
that in closing what I what I would say
is one should I did that not because I
have an interest in so much in
psychedelics that's another story but
what I felt when I did that but what I
can also feel through simply meditation
is sitting out in the universe floating
with no body and feeling that I am
connected to everything and to me that
is the most beautiful thing I better get
Mike that because they're gonna be on a
moment-to-moment basis doing exactly
that yeah exact thank you so much for
coming on the program we greatly
appreciate we'll go ahead and close out
the show rock the talk and then well
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
that was awesome thank you Jim will will
let's do part two let's Wow Wow
mind blown we love you we love you yeah
of course we close it out holy cow
Brady and Alan are gonna spend the next
10 seconds just
Wow Wow damn you can tell when someone's
been doing it for a long time
[Laughter]
Wow okay so thanks everyone for tuning
in to that episode with James Dodie wow
what a profound conversation that was
hopefully there were things in there
that that Jim shared with us that just
so deeply resonated that they can just
catalyze some significant profound
change in our life so no beginning no
end no separation I mean there were so
many of them guys check out the links in
the Bible Ohta to Jim's work also check
out the links in the bio below to the
transformative technology conference and
you know support the the conference
support Jim's work support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
the organizations around the world that
you believe in your communities you can
support simulation our links are below
you can find our paypal cryptocurrencies
patreon links down there you can also
design cool merch and get paid brady
stronger thank you so much for
co-producing this one whoa giggling so
much back there because it was at like
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
really looking forward to part two with
Jim that was fantastic much love
everyone we'll see you soon
[Music]